ich hatte heute auch ein thema sehr
bewegt und dieses thema ist eigentlich
ein sehr persönliches was ich auch sehr
traurig macht den stellen sie sich vor
sie selbst krank sie haben gerade eine
schwierige diagnose bekommen und werden
das krankenhaus eingeliefert ich habe
das zum glück nicht aber viele menschen
in diesem land haben dass sie geben
selbstverständlich ihren liebsten
bescheid und die wollen auch direkt zu
ihnen kommen aber das krankenhaus
verwehrt den einlass der grund die
korona bestimmung ich möchte ihnen hier
ein paar beispiele geben dem uniklinikum
essen ist nur eine person pro tag pro
patient erlaubt in den sana kliniken in
düsseldorf ist es noch schlimmer in
duisburg dort ist nur ein besucher pro
patient erlaubt und das nur für eine
stunde das heißt sie müssten dann
entscheiden ob sie geht jetzt der vater
geht die tochter und das nur für 60
minuten am tag das war's in vilnius
kliniken duisburgs extra noch erwähnt
dass kindern der zutritt als
begleitperson derzeit nicht gestattet
ist ich kann nicht verstehen wir das als
gesellschaft erlauben können wie die
politik das tolerieren kann ich bin mir
bewusst ist bei den betreibern das
hausrecht gilt aber ich finde dass wir
auf begehren müssen